الا ليت الشباب يعود يوما فاخبره بما صنع
المشيب يبدو ان الشباب اقرب لان يعود من
اي وقت مضى بالفعل وبعد تجارب اجريت
لثلاثه اعوام على الفئران والخلايا
البشريه باحثون يكتشفون جينات متحوله في
مجموعه من المعمرين تساعد على تجديد شباب
القلب تلك الجينات يمكن ان تعيد عمر القلب
الى الوراء باكثر من عشره اعوام بحسب
الاختبارات على الفئران والنقطه الاهميه
استجابه الفئران المسنه التي تعاني مشكله
في القلب بشكل الدراسه اجريت في انابيب
باختبار احتوت على خلايا القلب بشريه جمعت
من كبار السن يعانون مشاكل القلبيه حاده
ولعل الطب التجديد من ابرز التطورات
العلميه التي يشهدها العالم لمعالجه
الشيخوخه وتشديد خلايا الجسم الاعضاء على
سرحان
الطب والتجديديه يعرف على انه عمليه
استبدال او تجديد الخلايا او الانسجه
والاعضاء البشريه التالفه بسبب المرض او
العمر كذلك الاصابه لمحاوله استعاده
وظائفها الطبيعيه قبل تراجع كفاءتها بشكل
مشابه للاليات التي تساعد الجسد على شفاء
نفسه اللي طب التجديديه هو مجال جديد
نسبيا خرج للنور لاول مره في التسعينيات
ويمكن ان يساعد على التحسن بدون ادويه او
حتى جراحه ابحاث الطب التجديده لا تزال
جاريه لكن العلاج بالخلايا الجذعيه اصبح
شائعا وفي يزرع العلماء خلايا جذعيه في
المختبر خلايا مثل الموجوده في القلب او
الدم او الاعصاب حسب الحاله وتزرع لاحقا
للمريض للطب التجديدي يمكن ان يساعد في
علاج داء السكري من النوع الاول واصلاح
انسجه القلب والاوعيه الدمويه انواع معينه
من السرطان كما يمكن ان يحسن من كفاءه
جهاز المناعه
[موسيقى]
رئيس مركز الطب التجديدي في جامعه اوساكا
دكتور نورتنا شكرا جزيلا على تواجدك معنا
في صباح العربيه اهلا وسهلا الشرف اني
اكون معكم الله يحفظك طيب دكتور اكتشاف
جين جديد مضاد للشيخوخه يعيط صحه القلب
وشباب عشر سنوات الى الوراء اولا ما هي
هذه الجينات المضاده للشيخوخه وما هو الطب
التجديد وكيف يستفيد منها
طبعا
الحين في العالم كله هو
اطاله العمر باذن الله تعالى وصارت الحين
يعني الابحاث اقدر اقول لك انه خلال عشر
سنوات الماضيه تضاعفت 12 ضعف اما كانت
عليه خصوصا تركيزهم على هو واللي هو اطاله
العمر بدات مساله اطاله العمر لما يعني
بشكل علمي لما اكتشفت اللي هو الخلايا
الجذعيه المحفزه حق اللي نسميها
في 2007 كنا ناخذ خليه عاديه بعمر اربعين
او خمسين على حسب عمر الشخص ونبرمجها
ونعيدها الى عمر اربعه ايام عشان نستخدمها
في الخلايا الجذعيه فوقتها كثير من الناس
وحتى الشركات كانوا يقولون طيب اذا انتم
تقدرون تتبرمجونها من عمر اربعين الى
ثلاثين وترجعونها لعمر اربع ايام هل
تقدرون ترجعونها عشر سنوات او 15 سنه
فبدات الابحاث من ذيك الايام
في الابحاث حاليا بدات الحين فصار الموضوع
اكثر علميا وصار الحين
اللي هو اطاله العمر علم مستقل بذاته طيب
دكتور صفوق
كل شيء بالنظر حلو وجميل ورنان لكن
بالعملي هون بتيجي القصه وتدخل التفاصيل
هل تم التجربه هذه التقنيه على اشخاص انت
تعرفهم هل انت شخصيا يا دكتور جربت هذه
التقنيه مثلا وكيف كانت نتائجها طبعا هناك
لازم نفرق بين حاجتين تعريف وبنفس الوقت
ما هو العمر اذا كنا نتكلم على اطاله
العمر نتكلم يجب ان يطالع العمر باذن الله
تعالى الى عمر مثلا 100 الى 120 سنه لكن
في نفس الوقت يملك الشخص كل الاكتيفيتي
الطبيعيه مو انت تطول عمر الشخص الى 120
او 150 وفي الاخير هو على العنايه المركزه
هذا الشيء الشيء الثاني لازم نفرق بين
العمر العادي والعمر البيولوجي عمر
الخلايا اذا تتكلمين على عمر الخلايا له
مقاس معين فعلا في ناس يكون عمره تقريبا
اربعين خمسين ولكن لما تقيس عمر الخلايا
تلقاها في العشرينات والعكس صحيح في ناس
عمرهم على الثلاثين هل استخدمتنا في
بروتوكولات معينه هلا نستخدمها
اكون صريح اكون صريح ايه استخدم
هذا الجن او هذا الجن الى خلايا القلب
لاصحاب او الاشخاص يعانون من قصور القلب
تم تجديد عمل القلب وتجديد الاوعيه
الدمويه هل فعلا هذا ما حصل فتجدد الاعضاء
نعم طبعا هو الجيم
لاحظ انه الجيل هذا موجود في الناس اللي
يعيشون حياه طبيعيه طبعا مو نفس الجين هو
همم التحور في الجيم لاحظوا انه الناس
اللي يعيشون اعمار طويله موجود هذا التحول
فقاموا بعمل هذا التحور على ناس لا يملكون
هذا التحول فالخلايا رجعت وطالت في العمر
البايولوجيا وعمر الخلايا همم الى 10
سنوات الى الخلف وهذا على فكره التجربه
الاولى في مثلا طبعا يعتبر اعظم العلماء
في هذا الموضوع سنكلير اللي هو الرد وهذا
جربها على نفسه وعلى عائله
زوجه همم اخوه كانت اوردي يعني ماني بوز
وكده همم فرجعها 10 سنوات ورجعت الى
حالتها ابوه نفسه جربوا على نفسه ورجع
تقريبا اكثر من عشر سنوات الى الخلف ففي
بعض التجارب بس لا زالت على النطاق ضيق
طيب اليوم
بيقولوا لك الخلايا الجذعيه المستخلصه من
مشيمه الولاده لسه مسلسل هل هي مثلا غرار
الخلايا الجذعيه التي ممكن نتحدث عنها
لتجديد عمر الانسان ولا هو مجال واسعه
اصلا الخلايا الجديده مقسمه لعده اقسام
منها الخلايا الجنينيه من الخلايا الاي بي
اس المحفزه من الخلايا اللي هو المزن كامل
زي ما ذكرتي اللي هو الحبل السري والموجود
في الفات طبعا كل واحد له صفاته لكن اكثر
ما تستخدم حاليا في التجميل في التجميل
اذا تكلم همم تقريبا اللي هو المزين كامل
اللي ماخوذه من اللي فات من الدهون لكنه
اللي تستخدم للبرمجه تستخدم الخلايا عاده
المحفزه الاي بي
الشمري جرح قلب رئيس مركز الطب التجديد في
جامعه اسوان